Peggy 18  ladies and gentlemen the zero-point  dynamo means energy for all limitless  and free limitless  out of my way  haha looks like you found some trouble  alright who needs killing first  okay girl  our last chair you're pathetic  resistance is amusing but I am better  linked to 200 and [ __ ]  you want this orb so much well you can't  have it  Laurie bubby  any word from studio actually Laurie let  me call you back  sorry I'm late  Oh  Oh gotta take this  yo stunt double  [ __ ] man where were you  seriously Evelyn got away guys you worry  too much  the sequel just got great list  miss brimstone your so-called specialist  is just tore up downtown Seoul we're  paying you to raise an army of agents of  the street you are getting cold feet  then go beg someone else to save the  world from legion otherwise just sign  the cheques and shut up  a street gang hardly  you